you're watching a jewelry heist in
action it's November 2019 and thieves
have broken into one of the world's
oldest museums the cabinets in dresden's
green Vault contain precious Treasures
and the robber's axes make light work of
the glass
the group has already set fire to a
circuit breaker cutting the power to
surrounding streets so two can slip
inside
when they finished they'll spray the
room with fire extinguisher foam and
make their getaway
in and out in around 10 minutes here are
some of the 18th century Jewels they
stole
a large diamond encrusted bow
a sword
a diamond-covered breast star
21 pieces containing 4 300 diamonds
insured for around 113 million euros
and Germany today a court convicted five
men over the crime all in their twenties
they're believed to be part of a
berlin-based gang
in January four of the men agreed a plea
deal meaning most of the loot has been
recovered
without a deal there would have been no
return of the jewelry at least for the
foreseeable future
and it has also become clear that the
law enforcement authorities had no idea
where the jewelry could be so it would
have been very doubtful whether the jury
would ever have made its way back to the
free state of Saxony according to
an audacious Heist meticulously planned
the thieves behind it will now spend the
next four to six years in prison Siobhan
Robbins Sky News Berlin